Mais la seule politique qui a marché jusqu'à présent,
quand on regarde,
et bien c'est
des politiques où l'affichage est clair,
on ne régularise pas,
on ne laisse pas rentrer.
Voilà, l'Australie a 1 situation 1 peu
spéciale en géographique.
Mais le message était clair,
effectivement,
les morts en mer se sont arrêtés parce qu'ils savaient
que il n'avait aucune issue.
Quand j'entends, moi, la candidate,
le message de fermeté suffit à empêcher les candidats
à l'exil. Vous savez, on tente quelque chose,
on tente quelque chose. Quand on a,
quand on sait que
1 fois qu'on a posé le pied sur le sol européen,
bien on sera régularisé ou on restera.
J'écoutais madame ayet quand elle disait,
euh, on va voir en 15 jours si ils sont,
on va voir en 15 jours si on les garde ou pas.
Euh, madame ayet,
vous connaissez comme moi le
taux de reconduite à la frontière ?
Il est de même pas 10% en France.
C'est-à-dire, comment vous allez faire pour expulser ces
dizaines de milliers de personnes ? En plus,
le seul moyen
de les bloquer,
le seul. Ah bah oui,
parce que le pacte
immigration va
changer les lois en France et va permettre
de passer outre des décisions de la cour européenne de
justice. Voilà, non, la seule solution,
la seule solution,
c'est-ce que propose Marine Le Pen et Jordan Bardella ?
C'est effectivement 1
vrai référent d'homme sur l'immigration,
avec 1 série de mesures qui permettent
effectivement de rendre,
entre autres, ces. Expulsions
effectives aujourd'hui, à cause du droit européen en
particulier, on ne peut pas le faire,
non, vous êtes très en avance,
vous êtes très en avance.